what i've been giving you is
tana henka
maraishi dori
and you're seeing the form the natural
form that you see every day on a film
you haven't seen all the bits i've been
talking about so remember
it's not the bits you see it's the bits
you don't see that you need to remember
and work on
then we've done the kaitenagi
and i've said you get to here and you're
in the lightest position if this has got
more push than this it's wrong it's got
to be the same you know if you're going
to push hard on the hand push
hard on the head
my partner when he comes to come up
he should come up he should feel like
he's off balance that way right so
that's what we were doing this morning
he
i add to that by stepping through and
bringing the knee but he's feeling when
he comes up he should feel like oh i've
gone that way he shouldn't feel like he
can come up and then he finds a block
if he comes up a little bit and then
finds me blocking him
then it was wrong by me
so it should be
hand
meeting hand
linked
linked triangular so when he comes up
this is the feeling it's a little that
thin
you need to understand that
when we do the
thank you
and he tries to come up
yeah he's got the same feeling as he had
with the kaitenagi well that's what he's
so he's getting now information he's
going oh it's got that same little kick
that way
so that's what you're looking for so
we're putting it on film let's say
you're about to see it so that's what
you're looking for
okay experiencing the same
end result
now what i'm going to do is because
every teacher is nasty
at some point i want to give you the
hardest one i know
but where you come here and you get this
and you do an iccia
but at this point i'm going to remember
my murati dory and my shoulder even
though you won't see it he's going into
that back corner
now at this point
you've got either ichio because the
thumb's going down
or you've got nikkio because the thumb's
going into here
but if you do in like that and he's
strong
you use pow again if you can actually
use your body and about midway
i'm going to connect mentally this
this
and then nikki oh becomes an even amount
of power
you don't go take a bit of that
with the hands because you might not
have strong hands
but it's
it's a connection of a triangular
thinking done by the mind
all right so it's the hardest one i know
i could give you
most people get this hand and try and
take
the hand off with the hands
as you'll be finding out right now
well then
and saito essentially fascinated me how
he could make this look a beautiful
technique
so so easy
even way even everything so so keep
you know i've put on you a lot haven't i
because i've been doing this for years
but i decided with it's
cove it's been a strange thing i've
decided i might not be here next year if
i get covered
and that's not being negative it's the
truth
so
i thought i've got to get rid of this
stuff that i keep doing
i've got to give it away i've got to
give it you know give it away and so now
these workshops are designed to give it
away and for you to work on it for the
rest of your life or however long it's
going to take right so katadori
category
yukio
they all have the same
kaitenagi
understanding come on
all right i'll have this sign
that that feeling
okay it's a long way to go please talk